the cries of valor players everywhere
have finally been answered jet has
received a huge nerf the community has
been celebrating but is this nerf really
for the best or
did riot just kill jet
all right y'all it's a girl liz again
back at it again with another valerian
video valerian is to liz as tsm is to
danny so don't forget to hit that like
button that subscribe button and to ring
that notification bell let me start out
this video by saying for once let's be
nice to jet mains it's been a rough week
for them jet means you want some water
some snacks do you want i have an energy
drink are you okay now that the jet
mains are tucked away and resting
soundly the rest of us can bring out the
champagne because jet got nerfed baby
let's go
in all seriousness jet is getting a big
nerf on monday after patch 4.08 releases
instead of being able to instantly use
her tailwind or her dash a jet player
has to press the ability key once and
then press it again to use it within a
12 second time frame she doesn't use it
within 12 seconds it's gone like always
though you can still get it back with
two kills the reactions so far have been
pretty positive and some said it was
fine but maybe it didn't go far enough
the jet mains were understandably upset
at the nerf except for you know arguably
one of the best jets in the world durka
and some people made great jokes it's me
i made the great jokes i am the zoomer
of the office i hold a monopoly on the
memes i'm still not over heco retiring
so here is a clip of him reacting to the
nerf i like it you have to pick you have
like a little window when to dash or you
just insta double dash like you press e
twice and then you dash i think it's
good it just makes it so that like you
have to have some kind of you have to
put some kind of brain into when you
want to dash entry dashing still going
to be the same
but it's more
or less like the aggressive jet offing
you can't just insta dash away now so
it's a lot more it's a lot harder to
take an aggressive angle and be ready to
dash if you're not already in like that
dash now whether you're a ballerina die
hard or just a casual fan it's safe to
say that this is a pretty big change for
jet you see jet players had the luxury
of a get out of jail free card where
they could dash away at the first sight
of danger for a very long time her dash
also made her objectively the best asian
to op on until chamber came around so
why does this pretty big nerf exist well
according to riot a lot of different
reasons they said quote some of her
other impacts on the game have pushed
beyond valerian's core tactical cycle
and worrisome ways valrant's core
tactical cycle now if you're like me
your first thought might have been
what is this no like seriously just i
don't know what the hell this is lucky
for us they hyperlinked it with a lovely
photo of brim it is a circle with quote
intel plan and execute that is literally
the cycle it's your natural thought
process it's not that deep you get the
information you relay the information to
your team and you decide what to do that
information and you do it so where does
jets not fit into this well jet means
you might not know this but you tend
just to
go and do it a lot instead of hitting
all three points of valorman's tactical
cycle you get the intel and then you
execute there is no plan involved you
just get in and get out see riot spotted
a couple of main issues with her old
dash rya believes that jet players
didn't have to think as hard as others
or react to and rectify mistakes without
penalty they felt she had too much power
on the op and can get away from other
agents util too easily something they
keep harping on even towards the end of
the article is that they want jet to be
rewarded for making the right calls
jetstash having no prerequisites and
immediate use is her get out of jail
free card five people holding a site she
can get out walks into an op she can
zoom unlike other agents jett didn't
need as much info to execute her
and that caused an imbalance duelists
are expected to seek out those fights
yes but as a sentinel player or even a
controller
i cannot help you unless i know what you
are doing and when you are doing it
jet's motto literally could be no
thoughts just feed and that is a
hindrance to the rest of her team
whether jets know it or not but i know
what you're going to say liz what about
chamber what about yoru you're right
they have a very similar style of being
able to get out when danger is near but
baby what is the one thing you have to
do when you play those agents plan and
place your util you might be wrong
sometimes or your util might get
destroyed yoru and chamber have to
operate under more risk to get their
reward chamber cannot accidentally walk
into a missed op shot place both of his
tp's and then tp out in time before the
second op shot hits him think about it
this way right sentinel players like
myself have to set up on sites right you
put your util down and you hope for the
best sometimes you are wrong
but if you begin to notice enemy habits
and adapt you're rewarded for that game
sense riot wants their jets to use their
aggressive util and nature well not
carelessly so how can this all affect
pro play moving forward while a weaker
jet could open the door for other agents
we've already seen a shift to chamber as
the go-to opera and maybe this will help
accelerate that shift now if we could
predict everything about how the metas
would shift i would go buy a lottery
ticket but we can predict that this may
push jet out of the opera's favor
perhaps her role will return to what
many feel she was designed to do an
entry fragger that takes up space her
opponents may not be prepared for the
cold hard truth is if you are upset or
worried about this nerf you do not
understand the core part of this game
beyond the tactical cycle
it is a role-based team game we all have
our part to play and jet is a huge part
of that but just like everyone else on
the team in order to achieve our success
we need to work together that is
literally what riot designed for us to
do does it suck not to have a get out of
jail free card yes but welcome to
literally everyone else's world this
will absolutely take some getting used
to but i promise you that this is better
for the game's future as a whole i pinky
promise and i would never lie to you my
lovely valorant community let's just see
how this works out and jets i wish you
the best of luck when i peek you with my
op you're not going to need it
i want a complete overhaul of phoenix i
want him i have so many ideas for
phoenix you guys want to see me my my
like dream phoenix vision video
he could be so good and i feel like
right now he's a great beginner duelist
but like people and then he's there are
better duelists to use like jet but
our boy could do so much better